in our series the new normal we'll look
at how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives
as some movie theaters start to reopen
delays in the release of big movies like
the latest james bond film have forced
hundreds of others to close once again
more than 500 regal cinemas in the us
will temporarily close on thursday
the parent company that centerworld says
it's also closing more than 100 theaters
in the uk
around 45 000 employees will be affected
by that that's not good maria villareal
shows us
the big changes that some movie theaters
are making just to stay open
and keep the moviegoers safe from the
moment
you step inside it's clear things are
different
we'll just come in walk up to one of our
kiosks and they're going to select our
movie we'll do the comeback classic
of jurassic park the selection is
slim mostly classics with a cult
following
this is all new too this is all new all
this plexi is brand new and you'll see
it throughout our theater
hanging next to upcoming movie posters
are now big bright reminders of the
pandemic
requiring masks at all times megan
simpler is the chief cleaning and safety
monitor at this cinemark outside dallas
megan i can't believe i'm seeing this is
this true
so we are following the cdc guidelines
and recommendations
no refills but awesome pricing she helps
keep the hallways clean and filled with
hand sanitizer
and after every show monitors a crew
that disinfects
every seat the changes are definitely a
draw for these families
little piece of normal and a little
piece of something special for them to
get to do after they work so hard in
school this week what are you most
excited about
a movie yeah and the popcorn
all i have for you is a word
tell it a handful of movies have been
released during the pandemic like
christopher nolan's tenant
but it fizzled at the box office and the
film industry has lost
billions of dollars so far this year
it's been a big issue for the studios
which are also dealing with the problem
of how do we start producing films again
this is going to be a pretty big
financial hit all the way around for the
industry
there is some hope with the growing
popularity of drive-in movie theaters
but as the fall and winter months
approach traditional movie theaters hope
box office sales will make a comeback
cinemark has reopened more than 200
movie theaters across the country this
summer
they started promoting private watch
parties and roll back concession stand
prices
the resurrection of the big screen is
sort of like watching the ultimate
underdog methodically plot against an
invisible villain
in this case the coronavirus it's been
very difficult financially
mark serrati is cinemark's chief
executive officer he says the company
had to rethink how they do business
to survive popcorn is less expensive the
soda drinks are less expensive
and we're trying to just encourage
people to come back and to experience
how good it really is megan and her team
are hopeful
nostalgia will be enough to draw
customers back in
when the lights go down in this theater
what sort of change do you see
the magic starts to happen they start to
let go of what's going on on the outside
world and forgetting every
everything and immersing themselves with
the dimension or the universe that's
being
played on their screen for cbs this
morning
mideagle plano texas
i'm glad they're trying that i still
miss going tonight
we all could use a little magic right
now and i am with you i miss the movies
i really do no it makes me long for a
theater right now in new york
i want somebody to tell us what's the
best seat to sit in yes in a pandemic do
you sit in the back do you sit in the
front
do you sit by the door right
i think that's a good question and i'm
with you what you said yesterday about
missing movie popcorn well so apparently
i heard from a lot of people on social
media apparently there are a lot of
theaters that are selling
uh takeaway popcorns you just walk up
you don't have to buy a ticket the
theater's not even open but they'll give
you the popcorn
and you're supporting them now the big
question is do you get butter on it too
i love it when you can get butter on the
popcorn don't you